hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
famille
atout à chérie je t'aime qu'on a comme
on aime celle qu'on a cherché
éternellement et qu'on a fini par
trouver je t'aime parce que tu es mon
coeur tu es mon âme
j'ai mon corps je t'aime parce que j'ai
envie de vivre mille vie avec toi je
t'aime parce que je veux connaître avec
toi tous les mondes réel et imaginaire
je t'aime d'un amour inaltérable fatous
je t'aime à la folie je t'aime je veux
vivre tous les moments avec toi alors
faites ou je te le demande avec
énormément d'amour et tant d'ardeur ma
chérie mon amour est ce que tu veux
m'épouser
il faut bien
[Applaudissements]
ouais
non
alan et oui on a des eaux
bonjour